so you saw Mario Party 10 tell me about
it well so you know we saw mario party
back at e3 when they showed off what the
game is gonna be and I didn't play
around with any of the more regular
Mario Party trappings but I need to get
to spend some more time with what's
called Bowser mode which I'm actually
legitimately excited about because i
love that nintendo is still trying to
use the you know the wii u controller
because no other developer is really
using it in any way outside of like
here's the second screen i'm gonna play
games even the nintendo games coming out
but mario party is the same as Nintendo
land you know that game that comes
packaged with your wii u and that it
feels like this is a necessary component
for playing these games so in bowser
mode you're playing as Bowser and you're
holding on to your control like you're
holding the controller and the four
other player up to four other players i
guess you can totally throw in a
computer player in there but up to four
other players are playing wii remotes
and it's you versus then it's like
evolve but with Mario and with a lot
less shooting and no big monsters okay
so it's basically one players Bowser and
then everyone else is everyone else and
it's you versus them and if one player
gets coins is there like a general coin
bank or is it just go to that place I
mean so you're still playing mario party
on high for this we were just playing
mini games so it was kind of like up
pardon me be like a party setting if you
just want to jump in and play games but
otherwise I think it would function just
like regular mario party maybe where
you're going around the board and when
you instead of playing the four player
minigames you have five player option
for many games okay the one thing that
I'm not sold on from Mario Party is a
meebo functionality like Mario Party has
its own set of amiibo that we've already
seen you know you get another Mario
Luigi Princess Peach and putting them on
to the the gamepad you know which has
the NFC reader so that you can switch
out some of the boards that you see like
there's a separate mode for amiibo it
changes the look of the board that you
play on but it's still just a square
board and you're just playing regular
mario party going around in a circle the
amoeba will also have a power built it
so there's a like a coin or there's a
powerup that you collect as you're
playing with your amigo and you can use
that once per turn our or one sprig am
sorry once per game what are the
power-ups and any good so one of the
characters when you use their power up I
think it's something that we've seen
another mario party games but by putting
it on the NFC reader you get to like
roll more dice and these are powers that
you can we
you know give you a slight advantage
maybe two you know so if you're rolling
more dice on a used out on your first
turn you can get really really far on
your first go potentially getting more
stars and having advantage in that mario
party arena okay but at the same time
you're always playing on the same basic
level so it doesn't have the kind of
crazy weird levels that that mario party
has become known for its always a square
which is a little bit boring and and
having to move via meebo every time just
roll the dice is it's like that's too
much work for mario party i want to be
sitting and only moving my thumbs I
don't want to have to reach my arms and
work them there's no merging your its
kind remote controller like yeah that's
are you playing you're playing normally
with the wii remote controller just to
roll or to use powers use your amigo you
put them on the the NFC reader and you
can collect powers from other people if
you don't have an amigo you can still
play with other people who have a meebo
but your character appears on screen is
like a flat piece of paper and you're
like oh that's kind of lame so I'm
tentatively still excited for Mario
Party 10 I mean I'm not sold on the
amiibo stuff but the Wii U gamepad and
the functionality of that adds it can be
a lot of fun especially that Bowser mode
so I'm excited to play that with my
friends
bye